in the late 90s the enemy was was falun
gong but uh
you know they then killed them for their
organs and uh
there was the tibetans which they've
been targeting for a long time and
now that they've run out of the falun
gong organs they go to the uyghur yeah i
mean and actually you know we had a
guest on our show talking about how like
there's not a lot of falun gong
practitioners in china anymore of a
certain age group
because so many of them have been killed
for their organs and now the communist
party has just
moved on to a new group to get new
organs
what are they what do they use the
organs for transplants i mean
yeah i i think for like the people they
like for party matters
people can pay for it it's commercial
it's commercial i mean look at a human
you know
uh you know a human heart could be
retail for a hundred thousand hundred
and fifty thousand
a set of lungs hundred thousand dollars
dollars
yeah i mean so the the the value of a
human life in china
is very specific you know it's about 450
000 that's how much a human being is
worth
on the black market of of oregon trade
well not the black market because the
point
is chinese state-run hospitals
and so like what's happening with the
uyghurs like we know about the
concentration camps
right we know about the uh the how
they're treating women and and so on
uh but the thing that's not reported on
very much is
uh in xinjiang it is very likely
that a lot of those people are being
used as sort of a human organ bank
and when uh there's someone who wants an
organ they find a match from within that
concentration camp system
uh and they will do a speedy match and
there's a lot of
you know i don't know if you want to go
into it but here but there's a lot of
evidence to suggest that they are in
fact using uyghurs for that and it's
coordinated by the same system that is
doing the labor camp so it's all part of
the
the party's plan this is not some black
market
group or whatever doing it it's a fully
coordinated effort it's the way that
they subsidize
their medical system because the
government is not paying for it
right anymore they're not paying for the
medical system what's
sort of socialized healthcare but like
that's not really
a very accurate way to describe it
because it's very misleading
so uh well this it's socialized medical
care but it's not very good
but also like the state isn't really
giving it much money and so it has to
support itself
through the hospitals are yeah kind of
like their own
hospitals need to make their own money
and one of the key ways they do
that is through transplants so so
whenever we hear this argument that you
know the united states is one of like
three countries without
universal healthcare or something china
actually doesn't provide that kind of
coverage for people
yeah well i mean it's they purport to do
so but the problem
is that like like you can go to a
hospital
uh and that'll be provided but you'll
you'll still have to pay for your own
food in the hospital you have to pay for
your own nurses in the hospital
uh like there's a lot of things about
that system that don't work you have to
buy your own medicine it also depends on
who you are and where you are and what
kind of publicity there is going on like
during covid there was a lot of
the the the country is paying for the
medical care of these people who
are getting the credibility for everyone
you know yeah okay that's different
yeah that was for americans actually
yeah
yeah you foreign to go
well it's funny that you know look we
can talk about chinese china anal
swabbing american diplomats or whatever
but we are talking about organ
harvesting which is like
a little bit worse i would say it's a
little worse a little bit huh yeah yeah
like a lot of it worse but that system
the organ harvesting system has been
going on for a long time and as i
understand it it really ramped up
uh in the early 2000s uh because they
had all these falun gong in prison
and so they're like well what are we
gonna do with all these people and
they're super healthy because they've
been doing qigong
so wow you got you've got healthy people
they don't drink or smoke
they're in good physical shape perfect
yeah we want them to be like 28. and
they just
we're talking just billions of dollars i
mean this is really about money
you see that china did ramp up the
construction of uh
specialty hospitals designed
specifically for organ transplants and
this is at a time
when there is no organ donation system
in the country
wow yeah there's for a lot of cultural
reasons and whatever like
maybe in china all across china like a
few hundred people
or at most a couple thousand people are
like
volunteers like organ donors and their
system isn't even really functional in
most parts of china
so the vast majority of organ
transplants are from
non-voluntary donors and
they're not even executing enough
convicted criminals
to account for the tens of thousands of
transplants that are happening every
year
and so like these organs have to come
from somewhere and the
the reality is almost certainly that
they're coming from
uh one or more repressed groups falun
gong probably the biggest
uh maybe uyghurs now uyghurs uh
there's not enough falun gong uh organs
left
uh you know to some degree tibetans and
house christians i think
you mentioned that the the falun gong
are healthier is that is that
similar for the uyghur muslims they
don't drink things like that
with the weird it seems like there is a
specific uh
they they call it a halal organ right
for the customers in the middle east
yeah there seems to be a specific desire
for that in
those communities because they don't eat
pork they they're they don't drink
right and and so that so that's why
there's advertising
for medical transplant tourism in the
middle east to come to china
and there's even at the uh the airport
in urumqi which is the main city in
xinjiang
a sort of like fast track organ line you
can you can google it and find photos of
this
just like to speed up anyone who who's
boarding a plane who's carrying
organs uh so they're attracting middle
eastern customers
who are they're very ethical customers
who only want halal organs from muslims
ethical very ethical because they they
want the halal organs
harvest the organs of this innocent
muslim as well it's unclear if the
people getting the organs how much they
know there's a certain degree of
willingness i don't know i don't want to
know yeah like
it is not possible to order an organ
you you can't schedule it two weeks in
advance except in china you can though
wait wait wait wait wait wait china you
can schedule you schedule it on a day
typically
like about two weeks yeah have you guys
ever seen the movie the island with uh
yeah who was in it was it uh leonardo
dicaprio
and they're basically their clones so
that when when their
non-clone counterpart in the real world
needs an organ they harvest the clone
yeah so it's like you could order
as a wealthy person be like i'm gonna
need that you know heart and in a few
months and they'll be like okay and they
will start prepping
the clone for for harvest yeah i i
wonder
you know i'm not a muslim but i wonder
what the actual
scripture says or the teachings would
say about being a muslim
and then going and then having a country
that is subjugating muslims
taking their organs and then you as a
muslim are like i'll take that organ
i can't imagine that's right in like
in their religion you know what i mean
yeah but people within the same
religions have been killing each other
for
centuries so i mean there's always that
but i i think that the
the the people who are going to get the
organs i think they typically
aren't thinking about the source they
don't want to think about the source
uh and no one is
helping them think about the source and
so it's just like oh i'm just going and
getting a transplant
and that's a voluntary donor that is
what they will be told
yeah they will be told it and like and
they might have their suspicions but
they don't want to think
you don't want to let your mind go down
that path yeah right i guess when when
people are faced with death they need an
organ they'll believe whatever they have
to believe to justify their existence
i mean but like also the western you
know
medical system is supporting this uh and
they don't have the excuse of the fact
that there's they're facing life and
death because
the transplantation society has
willfully
not looked into this and have been like
uh like we don't see anything wrong
happening in china and
you know there's been a lot of brouhaha
over china has done a lot of cutting
edge
organ transplants like cutting edge
organ transplant research a lot of like
leading edge research
yes so like you know
a lot of the new drugs that are coming
out that make like
taking organs out of people like easier
like letting the organs
survive longer outside the body these
things are all coming from china
uh in the last decade or so and it's
because they're doing all of these
transplants yeah and you know it's it's
like a society that doesn't care
at all about the individual
that's pretty accurate yeah now it sums
it up uh yeah and unfortunately china
is uh trying to draw medical and
scientific talent from around the world
because uh they have access to a lot of
funding
state-backed funding and there's often
not the kind of moral restrictions
holding them back like in the u.s for
better for worse
you have all kinds of restrictions like
stem cell research is a huge issue
none of those kind of moral dilemmas
ever hold back the chinese communist
party
so like shelley was saying they're able
to make these breakthroughs
in organ transplant technology because
they have willing
[Music]
live don't uh test experiment willing
yeah
willing yeah the communist party is
willing to sacrifice them for the good
of the party
there was the guy who was talking about
head transplants and how he had
practiced it several times on oh yeah
yeah head transplant but they can't
connect nerves or anything like that he
was saying he was getting real close to
being able to do that
which is that he was failing each time
yeah yeah oh my god
yeah so there's definitely a lot of
really ghoulish things probably
happening within the
medical system what about americans if a
rich american went there
had money would they be alike whatever
you say sir right away
here's your kidney good sir i'm sure in
principle i like i have no specific
there are some countries that have
outlawed organ tourism to
china because like israel was one of the
first countries to do it actually
uh south korea has now taiwan has i
think these are there was a lot of
tourism coming from like south korea and
taiwan you know asia so
like one but once like this started to
become known and
then like doctors in those regions
started
speaking up and being like we should not
do this
but like it's still a very under the
radar
issue in general has the world always
been this way
or are we just in every possible
conceivable iteration of a dystopian
nightmare
book burning censorship zealotry
communism organ harvesting organ tourism
it's like all of these stories not just
here in the us but around the world and
it's like
it's like every single nightmarish
dystopian novel has come
into existence at the exact same time or
around the same time
it does make you think like it's always
been this way
well it's it's it just shows like an
inability for
people as a whole to really stand up to
these kinds of things or in
very very often what happens is they get
manipulated
by those in charge to go along with
these kinds of things to go along with
the censorship the book burning
the killing of you know the group the
bad group that's hurting society
it's very easy to be manipulated
that's that's the crazy thing too about
like in in the us not to derail too much
off of
china's internal problems but you know
they claimed
trump was demonizing migrants and
muslims
well they were demonizing american
citizens you know that that
so we we do see regardless of which
faction is trying to gain power
demagoguery and attacking a specific
group
seems to be the the strong path to power
well it's since you mentioned that
like xi jinping recently said the the us
is the biggest threat to china's
development
and imagine if biden said that about
china
or any u.s official i mean i think trump
said things
similar to that right he got a little
close but biden's gonna be like come on
man you know
china's they're helping us out they're
good people you know he's a master
diplomat
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you